I
'm Kazuya Kinoshita, 20 years old. I'm a college student living alone in Tokyo.
By the way,
I have a girlfriend.
I tried to close the distance,
but
[music] The
train is really convenient for going home
[music]
Maybe
I already
like it I'm a little excited about a better role I'm a little excited
Where is my dick going
Rental
girlfriend
[Music]
I don't know what I'm doing I'm sure I'll get a lot of ugly money anyway
Orange shirt and
striped pants It's
Kazuya, isn't it
?
Yeah
[music]
Cute
This girl's boyfriend must be
pretty
snobbish Umm... is that okay
?
Um, that girl is cute
That was a grow light I know the
details
Aquarium
[music] The
aquarium was active
So today was fun
Thank you again  I'm
a fool who doesn't even know the name of the fish.
I'm not going, I
'll tell you a word My
family
waited, it
took me a long time to find paper I
was worried about bringing it to Kazuya-kun, but I
don't know
[music]
Thank you.
I don't get depressed when I go on a date with someone and get paid I like this job I get
to meet people like Kazuya-kun
Owl,
is it okay if we
're
together as a couple?
Call it whatever you like Kazuya-kun,
take a look Kazuya-kun
Neon tetra
Cute
garden eels are
cowards, so they're always wrapped up in the sand.  You know, it's enough
for today's
sake What's the point in doing that
?  It's useless
Let's go for a moment It
seems like an idiot I
met
you I didn't even ask, but this guy was
n't loaned to me by a lover
You know what you're doing
stupid?  You
're an idiot,
even a rental girlfriend is that kind of promise
, isn't
it?  I
did something
strange to you, and my review went down by 0.3.
No, but
what I can see is that if it's a business obstruction, they'll do it elsewhere Seriously,
I can't.
But I get
it
Grandma, even
if I fall down, I have to go There's
still time left,
radish
I'm worried about passing out Mommy's body is still important, so please be
aware that your mom is an old
man There's also the store, so
it's the first time I've been hospitalized  Isn't this
room
with wi-fi? Mom
, I'll buy you a smart phone and a magazine for seniors. Don't
treat soft things at the same time
.  It
's
Kazuya, isn't it? It's Kazuya, isn't it?
I
'm sorry I'm sorry, thank you.
That Kazuya, who wasn't a woman,
is very
strong
[music]
Then I
'll go back to the store,
so Kaze will ask you to
follow
me.  Have you had sex yet? When
it comes to marriage, there's also physical compatibility
.
Grandma,
so this is acting, this is acting, this is acting.
It seems that there are quite a few, isn't it
?  You're saying it's dangerous,
but anyway, you have to get out of here.
Extension
Mr. Tanaka, don't lose your temper. Be careful
. Everyone's heart will
stop.
On the floor, what should I do
? I have no choice but to go out in pieces.
[Music]
This is
stupid, even if you say that without raising your voice, it's
really a pinch, but
what are you thinking?
I'm asking you
to grab me, but I didn't see a young couple
, but what did you
say you were going
to?
Music]
What are you
thinking rental? You have a girlfriend, right?
She's my granddaughter, I
'm sorry, but I'm sorry,
Grandma.
I was convinced
that he was Mr. Ichinose
's granddaughter.  It's been a long
time since I've been to blame I don't care if I let you lie to me It's a lot, so I want to introduce you to my family Do you think I'm a customer I kept this job a secret?
It's the best, right
, my parents' house Nagomi liquor store is the focus
What was made in my grandfather's generation is now
inherited by my father and mother.
That's why in
our family
Grandma is
like a
god God's dream
Will I be able to find a good person before I die I'm
also a grandma's child Before she
dies
I had a girlfriend I was dating, and when I
said I wanted to see my grandma, she turned me
down and
eventually dumped me.
No, it's
just that there are a lot of people that I can hide
Everyone's
hearts are filled with jobs and lovers
I'll
apologize to my grandma, and
someday
I'll bring my real girlfriend with me I'll do something with
my own power Only my
true self is
rented  I can't do it
[music]
What are
you doing? Damn it, don't
get me involved in
that embarrassing self-investment scene Even
if you're famous, you're
always making mistakes, aren't you?
I'm sorry and thank you
I have the same desire to make my family happy
But
I still can't quit this job No matter what I do, I
'm sorry for being like today But
if you think I'm a rabbit Call me
again No, I won't see Chizuru Mizuhara anymore  do not have
I
don't rely on you
anymore, the lover's play is over
[music]
And this is the
beginning
[music]
My
small
but positive
campus life Cars
How many
shots did you
pull out yesterday?  Wow
[music]
I guess I should get closer to you You're
staring at me without saying anything
[Applause] It
's days when I can't afford it I
'm not confident in bed I'm so pitiful that
you're dazzling The
time we can't meet plus the moment you smiled is
this  Time
[music]
If you notice it, it's the end See
you later
After you can't say anything about destiny, why don't you just get closer to yourself?
I wonder if we'll catch up, or if
it'll reach
[Music] The
broadcast is finally starting,
right?  Plus name fee + 30 second advance notice for next time
.